[Music]
welcome to session 75
in the worlds of speculative fiction
series this time around we are looking
at Terry pret's disc World Series which
is a ton of books we've got five of them
right here and we'll talk about why
those particular five books in just a
bit but let me tell you what they are
there's the color of Magic the light
fantastic sorcery Eric and interesting
time now the worlds of speculative
fiction is a monthly series that has
been going on since 2016 originally a
in-person face- Toof face series that we
would record held at and hosted by the
Brookfield Public Library with coid and
going online for everything that's what
we did with this series and now it takes
the form of what you're seeing right
here which is a video that I I shoot and
then Premiere and engage in live chat
anywhere from 90 to 120 Minutes going
into the World building philosophical
themes oftentimes biography and also the
authors take on their own work sometimes
responses to critics delving into
narrative series that do have a shared
world and that is definitely disor
discor is the narrative Universe for all
of these novels and they have a lot of
characters in continuity plenty of
satire as well as we're going to see
with for example Cohen the Barbarian um
but what we do in each of these these
sessions is talk about all those
different things we try to bring some
philosophical aspect and lenses to it
and we get to delve into what's going on
with these works so I have picked out
these five volumes in particular five to
keep it relatively
manageable because all five of them deal
with something that some of the other
books in the series do as well which is
a let's call them famous but not very
good wizard r vce wind and we get
introduced to him in the very first book
he is
arguably if not the main character at
least a
particularly Central character in all
the rest of these there are others as
well in which he features prominently
but we wanted to keep this relatively
manageable so we're just doing these
first five volumes that feature
rincewind as you know one of the central
uh points of view of the series and
we'll get to talk plenty about his
actual let's say qualities or lack
thereof as a character the development
that he goes through what what there is
of it and all the other people that he
comes in contact with including one not
a person but rather a sensient piece of
of luggage so with that uh we'll begin
our discussion of Terry pratchet his
disc World universe and these wonderful
funny little novels some of them
actually quite short like Eric most of
them you know fairly substantial and
some of the key philosophical themes the
World building all of those sorts of
things so sit back because we've got a
lot coming at you
next before we get fully underway and
looking at the world the narrative
Universe of these five novels and
talking about the disc World more
generally and then going into characters
and some important philosophical themes
not to mention biography of Terry
pratchet and some of the things he says
about his own Works in interviews I
think that if you indulge me we should
actually talk a little bit about each of
these books and I want to begin with
something that's quite amusing and
interesting that I discovered in doing
some research on you know the dis World
novels in general and it's a little
counterintuitive so the the first two
are the color of magic and the light
fantastic and a surprising number of
people who are actually big big fans of
Terry pratchet and of the series say
don't start with these because they're
really not that good and now isn't that
a funny thing to say about an author and
a series that you really love and so the
prevailing opinion among those who give
this sort of advice seems to be that
well you know pratchet was just kind of
like getting his legs and figuring out
what he wanted to do later novels like
you know sorcery or interesting times
which is you know much much deeper into
the sequence of it oh they're they're
much better plotted out and and written
and okay so there are a few differences
like interesting times is one of the uh
novels that actually has divided up into
sections and the others aren't right I
mean that ends already with the light
fantastic it's just a bunch of episodes
you could say and sometimes moving from
character to character but it's one
essentially continuous narrative as are
these other books but that doesn't make
a book Better or Worse having actual
chapters or stories so you know we have
to ask well is there really a difference
in the quality of writing and when it
comes to the humor I would say no I mean
Terry
pratchet like many other writers does
grow by his own you know admission over
time so we can expect that the later
books maybe are going to have a bit more
to them in in certain ways but I kind of
think that these first two
books you know they set the scene they
they tell you what's going on and they
introduced some of the very important
characters that we're going to be
spending a lot of time with in these
later novels
particularly rincewind but several
others that are very important as well
that we get to meet early on I mean one
of them is kind of in the background
much of the time the patrici of an
morpork
um but we also have this other guy
twoflower who's going to you know play a
role until he eventually goes back to
his own land but then we're going to
encounter him again and his children in
interesting times and in um the light
fantastic we get introduced to another
character who's also going to show up in
interesting times kohen the Barbarian so
I I I I really don't buy into this ooh
stay away from those first two books I
began with them and I thoroughly enjoyed
them and they made me want to go on and
read more of the series to see how
things in fact turned out so perhaps
that's bad advice perhaps that's a
wrong-headed judgment now let let's talk
about what's in each of these
books so the color of magic gets us
started with everything and I've just
got a few se c s uh that I wanted to
mention so you know rincewind and um two
flower are going to meet and this is
pretty early in on the book um rincewind
of course is this Wizard who's a
terrible wizard he's not very good at
all we're going to talk about why that's
the case I will mention one thing um he
was not particularly gifted to begin
with and then he looked into a grimoire
which uh contained the eight greatest
spells you know ancient time spells and
one of them like came out of the book
and got into his his head his soul his
mind and it's lurking there all the time
and it crowds out
him his brain space from learning any
other spells so as a wizard he's a
complete failure um he wasn't
particularly good apparently even before
before this happened to him and now he
meets um this stranger right he says
stranger if you stay here you'll be
knifed or poisoned by Nightfall but
don't stop smiling or so will I and then
the stranger says oh come now this looks
like a delightful place a genuine morian
Tavern I've heard so much about them you
know all these quaint old beams and so
reasonable too and uh he he he says um
my name is twoflower he extended his
hand instinctively the other three
looked down to see if there was a coin
in it pleased to meet you said rinn I'm
rinn look I wasn't joking this is a
tough place and then they're talking
about you know what's in the the mugs
the beer a single gold piece and um
because of the place that he comes from
the agotan Empire to flower even though
he's a poor man there is extremely rich
because he has gold which is very very
common so common as to be you know just
used for roofing tiles and stuff like
that in the agotan Empire where by the
way most of the action of interesting
times is going to be taking place and so
they get to meet and and you know hang
out with each other there's some
discussion a little bit earlier on the
part of these two characters that are
modeled after faford and the gray Mouser
uh
of things but we'll we'll jump ahead now
interestingly the Patrician of an morpo
the the ruler who actually runs things
it's a democracy one one man one vote
there's one man the Patrician and he
gets the vote for everything as we see
later on so he wants to know what's
going on and he finds out about
twoflower and then he meets up with
rincewind actually has him brought in
and then tells him that
um here we go come hither rince wind
would you care for a crystallized
jellyfish no and then he says I want you
to listen very carefully to what I'm
about to say otherwise you will die in
an interesting fashion over a period
since you are a wizard of sorts you are
of course aware that we lived on a world
shaped as it were like a disc and that
there is said to exist towards the far
rim
a continent which though small is equal
in weight to all the mighty land masses
in this Hemisphere and according this
according to ancient legend is because
it's made largely out of gold rwin
nodded who hadn't heard of the
counterweight continent some Sailors
even believe the childhood tales and
sailed in search of it they always
returned empty-handed or not at all
probably eaten by giant turtles in the
opinion of more serious Mariners because
of course the counterweight continent
was nothing more than than a solar myth
and then the Patrician says it does of
course exist although it's not made of
gold it is true that gold is a very
common metal there most of the mass is
made up by vast deposits of octarine
deep within the crust now it will be
obvious to an incisive mind like yours
that the existence of the counterweight
continent poses a deadly threat to our
people here do you by some chance fail
to follow me and the Patrician is
essentially talking about the
possibility of inflation get enough gold
into the coffers here and gold starts
losing its value right and so he says I
may as well tell you rinse when there is
some contact between the Lords of the
circle Sea and the emperor of the agotan
Empire as it is styled it is O only very
light there's very little Common Ground
between us we have nothing they want and
they have nothing we can afford it's an
old Empire rincewind old old and cunning
and cruel and very very rich so we
exchange fraternal greetings by
Albatross male at infrequent intervals
one such letter arrived this morning a
subject of the emperor appears to have
taken it into his head to visit our city
it appears he wishes to look at it only
a Madman would possibly undergo all the
privations of crossing the turn wise
ocean in order to merely look at
anything however he landed this morning
he might have met a great hero or the
cunningness of Thieves or some wise and
Great
Sage he met you he has employed you as a
guide you will be a guide rinse wind to
this looker this twoflower you will see
that he returns home with a good report
of our little Homeland what do you say
to that and then rincewind says oh thank
you Lord
miserably then the Patrician goes on
there is another point of course it
would be a tragedy should anything
untoward happen to our little visitor it
would be Dreadful if he were to Die For
example dreadful for the whole of our
land because the agotan emperor looks
after his own and could certainly
extinguish us at a nod a mere nod and
that would be dreadful for you rince
wind because in the weeks that remain
before the Empire's huge mercenary Fleet
arrived certain of my servants would
occupy themselves about your person in
the hope that the avenging captains on
their arrival might find their anger
tempered by the sight of your still
living body there are certain spells
that can prevent the life departing from
a body be it never so abused and I see
by your face that understanding Dawn so
all these threats and you know a little
bit of you can say there's no carrot
it's all stick right uh rincewind is now
charged with hanging out with and going
on on essentially Explorations and
Adventures with twoflower and that is
what the rest of the book winds up
being one of which is going to take them
into space they're
actually um you know well actually we we
should mention this
Wizards get to be killed by death itself
or rather taken harvested by death
itself and and they can see death and so
rincewind gets to communicate with death
who always speaks in all caps and uh we
we see death and fate talking towards
the end of the work rincewind and
twoflower are about to go off in a
rocket ship a a ship that will sail uh
be you know in in space and go down and
check out the gigantic turtle on Whose
back the entire world with the inter
inter mediary four elephants giant
elephants happens to be
situated so uh fate says to death I have
a task for you and death says well I've
got enough to do already and he says I
refer to the matter of the little
Wanderer and the Rogue wizard they die
in a few hours it is fated death stirred
and the stone began to move again I
thought you would be pleased said fate
death Shrugged I did inde chased them
mightily once but at the last the
thought came to me that sooner or later
all men must die everything dies in the
end I can be robbed but never denied I
told myself why worry I too cannot be
cheated snapped fate so I've heard said
death still grinning and so you know it
looks at the end of the book like these
two are finally going to meet their fate
their deaths together we have a couple
other you know interes things from this
this passage all those worlds tolower
said it's fantastic they're in a room
that has all the stars of the world the
universe portrayed on it and then
they're actually going to get into the
ship and take off now they're doing this
in part because they're being sacrificed
for that right um but they they are
actually uh doing some very
interesting uh things throughout this
and so they have all these cool
Adventures that are arranged here by the
time that the light fantastic the second
book begins we have them on the ship
right let's let's actually read a little
bit from this and this is giving us a
bit of the
world another disc day Dawn but very
gradually and this is why when light
encounters a a strong magical field it
loses all sense of urgency it slows
right down and on the disc world the
magic was
embarrassingly strong which meant that
the soft yellow light of dawn flowed
over the sleeping landscape like the
caress of a gentle lover or as some
would like it golden syrup um he goes on
no other world was carried through the
starry Infinity on the backs of four
giant elephants who were themselves
perched on the shell of a giant turtle
his name or her name according to
another school of thought was the great
a toin he or as it might be she will not
take a central role in what follows but
it is vital to an understanding of the
dis that he or she is down there below
the mines and seao and fake fossil bones
put there by a creator with nothing
better to do than upset archaeologists
and give them silly ideas great u in the
star turtle shell frosted with frozen
methane pitted with meteor craters and
scoured with asteroidal dust great ATU
and with eyes like ancient seas and a
brain the size of a continent through
which thoughts flow moved like little
glittering glaciers it goes on as large
as worlds as old as time as patient as a
brick actually the philosophers have got
it all wrong great uin is in fact having
a great time great uin is the only
creature in the entire universe that
knows exactly where it is going and as
we find out is on a journey that is
going to create some problems and
meanwhile um we have at the Unseen
University things going on trying to
figure out what is happening to Magic
and how rincewind might be connected
with this and we have um you know the
gods debating about things with each
other and then we get to rincewind and
and two flour and the luggage we should
also mention as well so there's a lot of
you know Adventures that they have
through this and here in this book we
get to meet Cohen the
Barbarian this is when they are um
rescuing a girl right um and by the
Light of the Torches they saw that this
was Was A Very Old Man the skinny
variety that generally gets called spry
with a totally bald head a beard almost
down to his knees and a pair of
Matchstick legs on which varicose veins
had traced the street map of quite a
large city despite the snow he wore
nothing more than a studded leather hold
doll on a pair of boots that could
easily have accommodated a second pair
of feet right and a little bit later we
find out who this guy is he of course is
a legend
right and uh they ask you know the girl
what's your name bethan is is her name
and she's rubbing green ointment into
the old man's back right and she says
well what's his name Cohen ish my boy my
name boy because of course he's missing
teeth Cohen the Barbarian the very shame
hang on hang on said rince went Cohen's
a big chap neck like a bull got chest
muscles like a sack of footballs I mean
he's the disc Greatest Warrior a legend
in his own lifetime I remember my
granddad telling me he saw him my
granddad telling me my my granddad oh oh
of course sorry yes said Conan inside
that's right boy I'm a lifetime in my
own Legend gosh said rince wind how old
are you exactly
87 but you were the greatest said Beth
and Bard still s still still sing songs
about you Cohen Shrugged and gave a
little Yelp of pain I never get any
royalties he said I that's the Shaga of
my life 80 years in the business and
what have I got to show for it backache
piles bad digestion and a hundred
different recipes for soup soup I hate
soup you know and he says it's my teeth
you see nobody takes you seriously when
you've got no teeth they say down
by the fire Grandpa and have some shoe
you know and so as it's going to turn
out Cohen's going to get a whole
mouthful of diamonds some some beautiful
Choppers later on as well and part of
what's going on in this work is the
magic is going away and people go crazy
about this there's an entire cult that
develops um and rince wind and uh
tolower and K the Barbarian and all
these other characters get caught up in
that right um they're killing Wizards at
the time by this time the luggage a
sensient piece of furniture essentially
which can it's got legs and can open its
mouth and eat people and uh spit out
things has become no longer so connected
with twoflower and begins to be almost
like a giant crazy dog following rinse
wind around and so we get a resolution
to everything nothing ever wraps up as
it's supposed to in this book and then
the next ones the ones that we're
looking at as well so you could say they
have the same sort of universe the same
sort of humorous approach but they're a
bit more thematic in respect so sorcery
is about the difference between
sorcery and magic magic is spells and
stuff like that sorcery is magic at its
most Raw it's most
powerful and what we have uh well I
should just read you the legend at the
beginning there was a man and he had
eight Sons the eighth son grew up and
married and had eight sons and because
there's only one suitable profession for
the eighth son of an eighth son he
became a wizard and he became wise and
powerful and wore a pointed hat and
there it should have ended but against
the Lord of magic and certainly against
all reason except the reasons of the
heart which are warm and messy and
unreasonable he fled the halls of magic
and fell in love and got married and he
had seven sons each one from the cradle
at least as powerful as any wizard in
the world and then he had an eighth son
a wizard squared a source of magic a s
surer and that
character uh there's a little battle
between death and the the Wizard um but
this character this boy who has a staff
in which his father has put his own soul
is going to come to the Unseen
university the the Locust of magic and
he is going to remake it in the image
that he desires of his own magic and
this results in quite a few Wizards
biting it you know dying off being
turned into things
um and then we we wind up you know with
lots and lots and lots of Adventures
going on uh because of this um there's
also uh Kina another Barbarian s who is
going to be hanging out with rinse wind
quite a bit and uh you know
Adventures
ensue um and by the very end there is a
kind of
reconciliation between the young
sorcerer and everybody else the young
boy his name is coin and uh everything
gets put back right again but again many
many funny
adventures Eric is a very short book as
you can tell right and Eric is somebody
who's going to summon rince wind um and
Eric thinks that he is actually a demon
sum Summoner and that rincewind um is is
a
um a demon himself right and so there's
there's a lot of interesting things that
are going to happen in this one there's
quite a few uh diabolical figures that
that show up uh wishes that get granted
and uh you know once again comedy ensues
now there's an interesting thing so you
notice there's this little Eric here and
it's written fa so this is supposed to
be sort of a retelling of the story of f
but in a very comic way then we get this
monster of a book interesting times
which is much later in the the disc
World Series and rince wind is going to
show up once again in this he's going to
get uh spelled off to the uh land that
um tlow originally came from which is
modeled after China and there's a lot of
well there's some Japanese elements to
it as well there's ninjas and Samurai
and stuff like that and so they wind he
winds up uh as as does Cohen and the
silver horde a bunch of other geriatric
barbarians who are
being I guess you could say LED Guided
by an old um and I don't mean old in the
in the sense that they are a
former uh teacher a former instructor a
professor who's left the academic life
behind and is trying to bring some
civilization to these Rough and Ready uh
Barbarian types he's trying to reform
them in the end he will actually die and
wind up going to their Heaven which is
Valhalla and they are going to take over
the agatan Empire uh from not just the
emperor but Lord Hong as well who's this
great scheming super competent guy and
you know rincewind uh gets mistaken for
being the great magician who will in
fact raise the Red Army uh and and he
does in fact raise a Red Army of
Terracotta soldiers which he loses
control of and all sorts of other very
interesting things happen and you know
the luggage shows up in this case too
the luggage winds up mating and
um having little luggage children the
size of you know purses perhaps with its
a spouse of sorts nobody knows how they
actually had sex or reproduced or what
they did but that's the stuff that's
happening in these these books so I
thought we'd do a little ROM to start
with and this may have taken a little
bit more time than I expected but now we
can jump in and talk a little bit more
about the world itself and some of the
important features of it and then go on
to talk about some biography uh because
I think that's quite relevant as
well we've already delved a good bit
into the World building found in these
disw World novels by Terry pratchet but
there's a few nooks and crannies that we
should explore a bit more and actually
they're not all nooks and crannies
they're they're pretty important parts
of the landscape the setting and they do
in fact inform the plot of a lot of
these novels as well and before we jump
into that I think one of the things that
we can say about pret's Discworld
universe is
that it's very malleable you can you can
develop more and more from it as so many
other great you know fantasy sci-fi even
I would say perhaps even horror authors
have done with their own narrative
universes it's uh it's not that it's
modular where you can just swap things
in and out but there's the capacity to
keep on exploring and not least because
a lot of the
narrators in the the stories are not
quite unreliable but not perfectly
informed either there's a lot of
uncertainty a lot of not of knowing
there's something over there but we're
not quite sure what it is and so you
know there's there's a number of things
that I've marked that I want to bring up
and so in the color of magic we get
quite a few important let's call them
descriptors being given which makes
perfect sense because Terry pratchet is
developing this world so he talks about
the Twin City of ank morpork foremost of
all the cities bounding the circles see
and he goes on to tell us that it was as
a matter of course the home of a large
number of gangs Thieves Guild syndicates
and similar organizations this was one
of the reasons for its wealth most of
the humbler folk on the wersin side of
the river and more pork porks Maisy
alleys supplemented their meager incomes
by filling some small role for one
another of the competing gangs right and
uh so there there's all sorts of people
involved and we get the the Trope the
fantasy Trope of the great City you know
and as a matter of fact the the
characters at the very beginning of it
who are modeled after faford and the
grey Mouser we can identify lanmar in
that or some of the other great cities
of fantasy novels you know everybody's
on the make as a matter of fact we'll
find out and I forget exactly where it
is in the books that uh an Mor pork has
its own distinctive smell a stench that
rincewind you know is is a little bit um
you could say homesick for at times and
you know it hits you and then he knows
that he's actually made it back to his
home City uh jumping forward a little
bit we're going to do this in kind of uh
episodic manners very much like the
novels um he writes the disc World
offers sites far more impressive than
those found in universes built by
creators with less imagination but more
Mechanical
Aptitude um though the dis sun is but an
orbiting moonlet its prominence is
hardly bigger than croquet Hoops the
slight drawback must be set against the
tremendous sight of great u in the
turtle upon whose ancient and meteor R
ridden shall the disc ultimately rests
right and uh he says perhaps the most
impressive site of all if only because
most brains when face with the sheer
Galactic enormity of ATU and refuse to
believe it is the endless Rim fall where
the Seas of the disc boil ceaselessly
over the edge into space or perhaps it
is the rimbo the eightc colored World
girdling rainbow that hovers in the Mist
Laden air over the fall and here he
tells us something very important eight
colors the eighth color is octarine
caused by the scatter effect of strong
sunlight on an intense magical field
eights turn out to be incredibly
important in these stories eight is the
number of magic right and then he says
or perhaps the most magnificent site is
the hob there a Spire of green ice 10
miles high rises through the clouds and
supports at its peak the realm of dun
manifest in the Abode of the dis Gods
the dis Gods themselves despite the
Splendor of the world below them are
seldom satisfied it's embarrassing to
know one is God of a world that only
exists because every improbability curve
must have its far end especially when
one can peer into other dimensions at
Worlds whose creators had more as he
says Mechanical Aptitude than
imagination and he says no wonder the
dis Gods spend more time in bickering
than in omnic cognizance and we get them
playing games with each other and making
Wagers not only in this novel but
throughout all sorts of other novels as
a matter of fact that is really how
interesting times begins right so we've
got uh the lady being introduced she's
going to make uh bets uh about and
against fate right so we've got some
some other really interesting aspects of
the world being built there coming back
to Magic right we have the in in an Mor
pork we have the the Unseen University a
massively important place because
Wizardry is indeed something quite
important and
um here we have an interesting little
reflection about
grimoire after the first age of Magic
the disposal of grimo began to become a
severe problem on the disc world the
spell is still a spell even when
imprisoned temporarily in parchment and
ink it has potency this is not a problem
while the book's owner still lives but
on his death the spell book becomes a
source of uncontrolled power that cannot
easily be diffused in short spell books
leak magic various Solutions have been
tried countries near the rim simply
loaded down the books of dead Mages with
Leen pentas and threw them over the edge
near the Hub less satisfactory
Alternatives were
available in inserting the offending
books and canisters of negatively
polarized oon right that that eighth
thing and sinking them into the
fathomless depths of the sea was one
burial and deep caves on land was
earlier ruled out after some districts
complained of walking trees and
five-headed cats but long before before
long the magic seeped out and eventually
fishermen complained of shs of invisible
fish or psychic clams a temporary
solution was the construction in various
centers of magical lore of large rooms
made of denatured OCT R which is
impervious to most forms of magic that
was how there came to be at Unseen
university the octavo the greatest of
all grimoire formerly owned by the
creator of the universe it was this book
that rincewind had once opened for a bet
he had only a second to stare at a page
before setting off various alarm spells
but it was time enough for one spell to
LEAP from it and settle in his memory
like a toad in a stone and then he's
talking with tlow and tlow says well
what happened he says well it vanished
from the page no one will know it until
I say it or until I die then it will
sort of say itself for all I know it
stops the universe or ends time or
anything so we've got rincewind carrying
around in his memory we often see the
spell coming to the surface getting
ready to be said right so um much much
later on we find them talking about uh
being in a strong magical field and then
we get this interesting little
reflection magic Never Dies it merely
Fades away nowhere was this more evident
on the wide blue expanse of the disc
world than in those areas that had been
the scene of the great battles of the
Mage Wars which happened very shortly
after Creation in those days magic and
its raw state had been widely available
and been eagerly utilized by the first
men in their war against the gods the
precise origins of the Mage Wars have
been lost in the fogs of time but dis
philosophers agree that the first men
shortly after their creation
understandably lost their temper and
great and pyrot techic were the battles
that followed the sun wheeled across the
sky the Seas boiled weird storms ravaged
the land small white pigeons
mysteriously appeared in people's
clothing and the Very stability of the
disc was threatened this resulted in
Stern action by the old high ones to
whom even the Gods themselves are
answerable the gods were banished to
high places the Pinnacle right and men
were recreated a good deal smaller and
much of the old wild magic was sucked
out of the Earth this did not solve the
problem of those places on the disc
which during the wars had suffered a
direct hit from a spell the magic faded
away slowly over the Millennia releasing
as it decayed myriads of subastral
particles that severely distorted the
reality around it and so we've got you
know a world this you know flat disc
world where there's pockets of old magic
and this whole back history and we see
that in sorcery there is this
possibility of magic being restored to
the old days right by the eth son of the
eighth son uh who is a wizard right so
um coming back actually to this this
book uh sorcery let's look at something
we'll go back to the city of an morpork
spring had come to an morpork it wasn't
immediately apparent but there were
signs that were obvious to the kogos
scany for example the scum of the river
ank the Great Wide slow waterway that
served the double city as Reservoir
sewer and frequent morg had turned a
particularly iridescent green the city's
drunken rooftop spouted mattresses and
bolsters as the winter bedding was put
out to air in the weak sunshine and in
the depths of musty cellers the beams
Twisted in Grown when their dry sap
responded to the ancient call of root
and
Forest Birds nested among the gutters
and EES of unseen University though it
was noticeable that however great the
pressure on the nesting sites they never
ever made nests in the invitingly open
mouths of the Gargoyles that line the
rooftops much to the gargoyle's
disappointment a kind of spring it even
come to the ancient University itself
tonight would be the eve of small gods
and a new Arch Chancellor would be
elected not exactly elected because
Wizards didn't have any truck with all
this undignified voting business and it
was known that well known that Arch
chancellors were selected by the will of
the Gods and this year it was a pretty
good bet the gods would see their way to
clear to selecting old viid wus who was
a decent old boy and had been patiently
awaiting his turn for years and as we
find out the arch Chancellor doesn't
really do magic more
Administration and there's this entire
like hierarchy of ranks of Wizardry much
of which has to do with people below and
above competing with each other trying
to the lower try to kill the older and
higher rank to get them out of the way
so they can move into their spots and
then have to deal with that sort of
paranoia themselves um we find a few
other interesting things and remember I
was talking about the you can always
expand on this so in Eric um Eric and
rincewind go to hell and here's a very
interesting
description hell was not what rincewind
had been led to expect although there
were signs of what it might have once
been a few clinkers in a corner a bad
Scorch mark on the ceiling it was hot
though with the kind of heat you get by
boiling air inside an oven for years
hell it has been suggested as other
people this has always come as a bit of
surprise to many working demons who had
always thought that hell was sticking
sharp things into people and pushing
them into lakes of blood and so on this
is because demons like most people have
failed to distinguish between the body
and the soul the fact was that as droves
of demon Kings had notice there was a
limit to what you could do to a soul
with for example red hot tweezers
because even fairly evil and corrupt
Souls were bright enough to realize that
since they didn't have the concommittant
body and nerve endings attached to them
there was no real reason other than
force of habit why they should suffer
excruciating Agony so so they didn't
demons went on doing it anyway because
numb and Mindless stupidity is part of
what being a demon is all about but
since no one was suffering they didn't
enjoy it very much and the whole thing
was pointless centuries and centuries of
pointless igle had adopted without
realizing what he was doing a radically
new approach demons can move
interdimensionally and so he'd found the
basic ingredients for a very worthwhile
Lake of blood equivalent as it were for
the soul learn from humans he told the
demon Lords learn from humans it's
amazing what you can learn from humans
you take for example a certain kind of
hotel it is probably an English version
of an American hotel but operated with
that peculiarly English genius for
taking something America American and
subtracting from it it's one worthwhile
aspect so that you end up with slow fast
food West country and western music and
well this hotel it's early closing day
the bar is really just a pastel pink
panel table with a silly ice bucket on
it set in one corner and it won't be
open for hours yet and you add rain and
let the one channel available be on the
only TV be perhaps Welsh Channel 4
showing its usual muus iced and food
from ponti gal and there's only one book
in this Hotel left behind by a previous
victim it is one of those where the name
of the author is on the front in raised
gold letters much bigger than the title
and it probably has a rose in a bullet
on there too half the pages are missing
and the only Cinema in town is showing
something with subtitles and French
umbrellas in it and then you stop
time but not experience so that it seems
as though the very fluff in the carpet
is gradually rising up to fill the brain
and your mouth starts to taste like an
old denture then you make it last
forever and ever that's even longer from
now until opening time and then you
distill it so he says of course the disc
World lacks a number of the items listed
above but boredom is universal and as
figle had achieved in Hell particularly
High brand of boredom which is like the
boredom you get which is a costing you
money and B is taking place while you
should be having a nice time right very
interesting rework king of Hell taking
things from our world and putting them
into a sort of equivalent within the
part of the disc world that is hell um
there's only one other thing that I'd
wanted to bring up a passage because
there's something else that we need do
need to say about World building a kind
of
spillover so you know um interesting
times takes place mostly on the
counterweight continent in the agotan
Empire and we have this very interesting
description of the Great Wall it
completely surrounds the agotan Empire
the word is
completely it is usually about 25 ft
high and sheer on its inner side it is
built along beaches and across howling
deserts and even on the lip of sheer
Cliffs where the possibility of attack
from the outside is remote on subject
islands like bang bang duk and tingling
there are similar walls all
metaphorically the same wall and that
seems strange to those of a non-thinking
milit Ary disposition who do not realize
what its function really is it is more
than just a wall it is a marker on one
side is the Empire which in the agotan
language is a world identical with
Universe on the other side is nothing
after all the universe is everything
there is oh there may may appear to be
things like sea Islands other continents
and so on they may even appear solid it
may be possible to conquer them walk on
them but they're not ultimately real the
agotan word for Foreigner is the same as
the word for Ghost and only one brush
stroke away from the word for victim the
walls are sheer to discourage those
boring people who believe in believe who
persist in believing there might be
something interesting on the other side
amazingly there are people who simply
won't take the hint even after thousands
of years the ones near the coast build
rafts and head out across lonely Seas to
lands that are aable the ones Inland
resort to man carrying Kites and chairs
propelled by fireworks many of them die
in the attempt of course but the others
are soon caught and made to live in
interesting times but some did make it
to the great Melting Pot called ank Mor
pork they arrived with no money Sailors
charged with charged what the market
would bear which was everything but they
had a mad gleam in their eye and they
opened shops and restaurants and worked
24 hours a day people called this the an
Mor pork dream of making piles of cash
in a place where your death was unlikely
to be a matter of public policy and it
was dreamed all the Stronger by people
who didn't sleep so we get uh you know
the other thing that's that's talked
about in this is that in the agatan
Empire they don't need whips to control
people and there's something worse than
whips anyway so that that's some of the
the World building you know we're going
to do another uh session on some of the
other books and we'll do some of the
more more of the World building and
exploration then I do want to say
something though before we close out
this uh little
discussion
so this
world developed as what you know tolken
or Len or others would call a secondary
World an imagined world uh by Terry
pratchet an author existing in our world
uh and developed at Great length has
spun off its own let's
say colonies within our own world and
here we might actually think of
something like Jorge Lou Borge's famous
story
umbaran orbus terus where an imaginary
world begins to invade and even in some
respects change our own disc world is
not quite done that but outside of the
novels we have this vast imaginary
space so there are to to start with
there are disor conventions where people
who want to geek out about dis world can
get together held alternate years in
Great Britain and in the United States
there have been interestingly dramatic
stage adaptations from the 1990s onward
of particular novels or stories or
vignettes and not just like one or two
but a whole slew of these going on for
quite a while I'm not even going to talk
about you know TV and radio adaptations
um I think the dramatic thing is more
interesting because people have to
decide to participate it people have to
show up to watch it and uh participate
in their own way in this weaving of a
collective illusion and
Imagination um there are also video
games and one of the first video games
came out in
1986 came out actually for a computer
that we had I didn't ever have this game
uh but it's quite interesting a now
defunct platform from a company that as
far as I know is long been out of
business the Commodore 64 right one of
the early home computers that was quite
affordable and actually quite good um
there was a game called the color of
magic that you could play on it later
there were other video games like
um disc world and disc World 2 where you
could play rinse win who was voiced by
Monty pythons Eric Idol you know so
we've got the humor aspect in there
there was a later game called disc World
Noir where you play a private
investigator named Luton there's all
sorts of other games that people have
come out with you know some are based on
cards or board games you have battles
you have competitions you have quests
and all sorts of interesting things like
that there are even people who have
developed games based on games mentioned
mentioned in the dis World Series um and
there are dis World websites including
an entire disc world and Terry pratchet
Wiki but the one that I wanted to save
for last that I think is really quite
interesting Steve Jackson games a long
time ago really I I I want to say maybe
it was in the 80s or maybe it was in the
90s came out with something called gerps
the generic Universal roleplaying system
and this was a a fairly openend
roleplaying uh manual that you could add
all these interesting modules to so you
could play something that was like
traditional DND you could actually take
Car Wars which was another Steve Jackson
game and turn it into a role playing
game there was a module for the British
show the The Prisoner and there were not
one not two but three different
iterations of games uh for the disc
world so you could play your favorite
characters and you'd have a you know a
game master running the show behind it
you could play rincewind you could play
Cen the Barbarian you could play all of
these other
interesting types right and I think that
this is really something that you know
it's not just a series that captivated
people's attention and that they could
as I said geek out about with fellow
people who are equally interested
equally excited about that I think
that's really quite important but you
could actually turn it into something
that you could play not just act out but
play
imaginatively
expansively together with rules that
would sometimes have to be broken or
super seeded isn't that fascinating I
think there's much more to be said about
that but I I don't want to go too uh far
into the weed so this is probably enough
about about World building a World
building that generated a secondary
world that then came to have its own
colonies within our
own Terry pratchet had a long and quite
rich life he dies a little bit young
unfortunately at 66 years old but he
packs a lot of living and a lot of
interesting living as we we'll see into
that time so he's born in
1948 in Beaconsfield so a little bit
north of London to David and eileene a
mechanic and a secretary both carrying
the patet name at that point in time and
he goes to school he doesn't really
enjoy it too much apparently the uh uh
head teacher what we would call a
Headmaster is kind of a jerk and and uh
he's not doing great his family moves
and then eventually this opens up the
possibility to attend uh yed Technical
High School and there he actually seems
to flourish quite a bit he gets involved
in writing and publishes his first story
business rivals in the technical signate
which is actually going to be the the
literary magazine of the high school
this will actually be published later uh
as Hades business in 1964 a very early
story and he credits the local library
for you know really contributing to his
education I think it's something that a
lot of us can relate to if the schools
that we went to were okay were adequate
but not you know really Stellar in in
all respects and it it's as a side note
it's really quite good to get used to
going to the library and doing your own
reading and re research and reflection
rather than just taking what people give
you in in
classes um in 1963 and 1964 he begins
attending sci-fi conventions he's
already doing a good bit of writing on
his own at this time and then he's going
to start a levels in English art and
history in
1965 he uh leaves school and he begins
doing things that are going to really
build him as a writer you might say he
has an apprenticeship at boxfree press a
place where he will work and you know
leave and come back to several different
points in 1968 he visits the publisher
Colin Smith Limited in order to
interview the editor uh uh Peter band
and uh that is going to start an
important collaboration or you could say
uh business business relationship
because his early books are going to be
published at that that house he also
marries uh Lynn pervis that year and you
know now establishes a household they
will be involved with each other
throughout his his life uh 1970 he
becomes a reporter and he actually you
know credits being a reporter is very
important for development as a writer he
starts WR wrting for the Bristol Western
Daily Press which you know sounds quite
good in 1971 he leaves there and um in
that year Colin Smith publishes his
first novel the carpet people which is
actually uh you know more oriented
towards children in 72 he returns to the
buck Free Press and becomes a sub editor
so he's making his living as a literary
person but not so much just as a writer
in the the you know classic sense of
writing big books that are very
important I mean that is going to come
um in 73 he starts work at the bath and
West Evening Chronicle in 1976 the Dark
Side of the Sun is published a Sci-Fi
novel his daughter Rihanna is is born
and then in
1979 the very kind of funny turn of
events he gets hired by the Central
Electric
generating board in in Bristol as well
to become a public relations officer now
this is if you remember your history
around the time that people got really
really nervous about nuclear power
because the Three Mile Island uh event
which turned out to be less catastrophic
than it was originally portrayed
happened and so he's thrown into you
know hey you got to start making some
good Arguments for why we shouldn't
close down all the nuclear plants right
away um in 1981 he publishes another
novel strata uh and in
1983 we get the first disc World novel
The Color of magic um he's going to
follow that up in 1986 with the light
fantastic and let's just pause for a
moment the color of magic really
captures people's attention um it it
gets you know read very widely people
are like oh this is really great stuff
and remember you know that around this
time we have some other humorous
writings going on in sequences The
Hitchhikers Guide to the Galaxy uh with
Douglas Adams we have over in
America uh the zanth novels coming out
so it's it's not as if there isn't
anybody else doing similar things but
these are in Britain you know and we
could make a connection with hitchhiker
Guide to the Galaxy because
the not just publishing but also you
know television and radio world and we
could even say the world of drama are
more centralized and people get to know
each other in ways that doesn't happen
quite as easily here in America it's
possible to have all these cool
adaptations and the color of magic gets
you know brought in for those sorts of
things and then people like this this
feeds the desire for more of this stuff
right and you know the light fantastic
does not disappoint so going on in
1987 he publishes equal rights and Mort
and here we see an important
change so golance is a really important
publisher at that time primarily of
sci-fi stuff although the Sci-Fi stuff
could also be considered fantasy
depending on you know where your
borderlines lie and so they take on
pranet and at first give him a six-book
contract now that's important advances
this means that you can be essentially
an independent writer and at this point
in time uh Colin Smith retains its
relationship and but not as his
publisher but rather as his literary
agent so you know that's that's quite
helpful to have a powerful you know uh
person or firm in your corner that way
in 1988 we see uh
the next one that we're looking at
sorcery come out along with um weird
sisters another one of the witch novels
1989 pyramids guards guards 1990 we have
Eric and um uh many um many puncture and
then from this point onward we're going
to see one or two books come out a year
all the way to 2007 as a matter of fact
there's actually one year where he
publishes three books and these are I'm
only talking about the dis World Books
he publishes other things as well he
contributes to a lot of Collections and
he's got collaborations going on but
just in the disc World thing the the
amount of productivity is pretty amazing
and you know pratchet is going to credit
this in part to having had this
apprenticeship writing before you know
he's uh recognized doing all this
technical writing all this reporting all
this deadline work um he actually says
that if you want to be a good writer you
need to write not only within your genre
but also outside of your genre which is
kind of a fascinating idea to to to work
through anyway um a few other things
that that he writes that we should bring
up because I'm not going to go through
the entire list in 1989 the the
unadulterated cat a bunch of anecdotes
about cats haven't read it but I really
do want to because uh you know I love
cats and I think pret is is really great
1990 a lot of people probably know this
already Neil Gaiman and him collaborate
on good Omens which is come out as a
series I believe on Amazon uh perhaps um
so you know that that's probably enough
about the the literary stuff um what
about his recognition and awards so in
1990 he is the first guest of honor at
octocon octo because the eighth color is
that of magic as we find out in the
color of magic he was awarded 10
honorary doctorates beginning with uh
University of Warwick in uh 19 um 99 um
he was made an Adjunct professor of
English at Trinity College Dublin in
2010 which is a nice honor there but you
actually do have to teach some classes
uh he won a lot of awards I'm just going
to give you some of the highlights of
these so British sci-fi award in 1989
for pyramids a locust award for making
money as well in 2005 going postal is
actually a candidate for the Hugo award
it's hard to get higher up than that but
he recuses himself because he says I
want to enjoy myself at World con this
year I don't want to be bothered with
this in 2010 there's two really
important Awards the Andre Norton award
but also the world fantasy award for
Lifetime Achievement that's really quite
quite cool
2016 um he is awarded uh postumus the
Sci-Fi writers of America Kate wilham
solstice's award for significant impact
on sci-fi fantasy landscape now that's
kind of a double thing right he
influences other writers so that's the
landscape but Discworld is itself a
landscape a flat Earth uh on a turtle
right so that's kind of a cool thing I
think a lot of people probably know that
he he was Sir Terry pratchet right in
1998 he was awarded the uh order of the
British Empire and then in 2009 he was
knighted the KN Bachelor he said that's
a really cool thing as a fantasy author
you can't turn down the the Knighthood
and he actually had a sword forged for
himself but something else that I think
is really quite cool about him
biographically and this is not just in
terms of these Awards but something else
that we'll talk about and we'll close on
in 2011 he sponsored an award himself
the Terry pratchet first novel award
which is as you can guess awarded to
great first novel writers to help
support them in their work and so you
know this is kind of emblematic of
pratchet I think you see this in the
books but you see this in his life as
well he doesn't forget about his
struggles he doesn't forget about where
he came from he doesn't forget about
people who are doing something similar
to himself and so now this is a great
lead into uh what ultimately leads to
his demise in 2007 at first they believe
he has a stroke but that's actually a
misdiagnosis it turns out that it's
early onset Alzheimer disease and he
also has posterior cortical atrophy or
PCA as well now it doesn't take him long
it's just a year and he donates $1
million to Alzheimer research and he you
know people ask well why' you do this
and he says well it's totally
underfunded it's you know I looked into
it and there's very little going into it
compared to say cancer research and you
know this is quite preent I mean we live
in a society that is aging here in in uh
you know the the what we call the weird
countries right the Western countries
that are also capitalist and
industrialized and uh it's pretty pretty
important right so he is not just going
to suffer with his disease and find ways
to keep on being productive and
accommodate himself he's going to
actually do things about it but without
having the metaphor of fighting the good
fight or something like that um also in
2008 he collaborates with the BBC to
produce a documentary about Alzheimer's
disease so you know he's giving back in
another way and using what we could call
his bully pulpit uh in 2015 he's going
to die age 66 of complication due to
Alzheimer's disease there was a little
bit of speculation that maybe he had
taken his own life because he had he had
written about that and said you know if
it gets bad enough perhaps that's the
way to go uh but his family confirmed
that it was it was simply natural causes
and this brings the story of Terry
pratchet to a a close but his influence
continues going on me it's almost 10
years at this point since his de eyes
and he's still massively influential and
his legacy continues to exist not only
in his own achievements but in what he
himself decided to do with his money
with his time with his attention with
his Prestige and I think that's a great
thing to close on there's a kind of
generosity there that you don't always
see among
writers terrie pratchet has given a
number of interviews over the course of
his long career and some of them can be
quite Illuminating to take a look at
particularly those in which he is
talking about fantasy as a genre as a
type of literature and how we should
value and evaluate it he also talks
about a lot of other things as well that
I think are quite important for
understanding where he's coming from as
an author and so where I want to begin
is actually from disworld domcom and
it's a fairly short thing he says
truthfully without egging it as I often
do the library and journalism those
things made me who I am journalism makes
you think fast you have to speak to
people in all walks of life especially
local journalism London journalism can
go and he's got a exploitive here uh
sort of dashed out in somebody's face
and they can't do anything about it try
that in local journalism and someone's
down to complain everyone should have
one local journalism job in their lives
especially if they're a nosy Parker I
interviewed an elderly journalist who'
worked in a small town for a very very
long time I asked is it boring and he
said over there that's where a couple
pushed their daughter into the attic
because she'd had a black baby and over
there that's where a man was caught in
flagrante decto with a barnyard fowl and
he said to the magistrates well it was
my foul even those small moments they
make you realize the world is not as you
thought and so journalism is a you know
type of writing but it's also research
information gathering and even thinking
about the nature of the world that we
are in and so
pratchet is saying that this is part of
of what has led to his style now in the
internet writing journal he's asked I
wonder what percentage of the readership
actually catch all of the jokes perhaps
each person gets a different Easter egg
so to speak and then pratchet responds
and he says that I think is one of the
keys to the success of this world the
disc World although I never set out to
do things like that I don't think anyone
gets everything
but I think nearly everyone gets 80 to
90% of the references in the book but I
hope that the things that they don't get
they don't notice that they're not
getting if you follow me there's a
character mentioned in the book although
he never appeared because he's dead
called bloody stupid Johnson who's the
opposite of a genius he's the kind of
the negative image of Leonardo da Vinci
he's built various things that don't
work and they all failed to work in a
most spectacular way one of the things
he built is the mighty orgon at the
Unseen University
which can make the most astonishing
array of sounds there's a scene in one
of the books where one of my characters
is at the ank Moro uh Opera House the
opera house is Oregon has been busted
and needs some spare parts so the
character says well I've been in touch
with the university and it's a marvelous
thing it turns out that our organ is a
Johnson now no one in England is going
to get that line but most Americans
probably will myself included but it
doesn't actually matter to me that no
one in England will unless they've
watched a few American movies because
they're not going to notice It
ultimately I put those things in because
I think it will be fun at that point
isn't that an interesting thing to say
about his use of humor and we're going
to come back to this in just a bit
particularly with a comparison to
another Great British author uh who
wrote some pretty funny novels as well
but continuing on with this
interview um he's asked it seems that
the disc World novels have gotten a
touch darker perhaps with a few more
serious bits in them is that an accurate
statement of how the series has evolved
and uh pratchet says first off I have to
say I hate it when reviewers call my
work wacky or zany those people are
going to be hunted down by the mafia
seriously I hope around the fifth or
sixth disc world book I discovered the
joy of of plot I think it was Esther
freezer who said you have to have tragic
relief not just comic relief tragic
relief if a book is nothing but funny
then it is nothing but funny there's no
contrast and it's hard to take anything
seriously it's hard to worry about the
fate of a character you do need those
moments where you bring people down to
earth so a balancing of the serious and
the comic together now we got get a very
funny response from uh pratchet in an
interview that's become quite famous for
how a seric his response is carried out
in one of our hometown papers actually
just the next big town over Madison the
onion which many of you probably know as
an important uh website out there a
parody website so he's asked this why
write fantasy it's a rather ghettoized
genre and pratchet says well that's true
I can't speak for the US where I merely
sort of sell okay but in the UK I think
every book I've done 20 in the series
since the fourth book everyone has been
one of the top 10 National bestsellers
either as a hard cover or paperback and
quite often as both 12 or 13 have been
number one I've done six juveniles all
of those have nevertheless crossed over
to the adult bestseller list on one
occasion I had the adult bestseller the
paperback bestseller in a different
title in a third book on the juvenile
bestseller list now tell me again this
is a ghettoized
genre and then the the onion reviewer
says well it's certainly regarded as
less than serious
fiction size that's actually in there in
parenthesis pratchet says without a
shadow of a doubt the first fiction ever
recounted was fantasy guys sitting
around the campfire was it you whoot the
review I thought I recognize it guy
sitting around the campfire telling each
other's stories about the gods who made
lightning and stuff like that they did
not tell one another literary stories
they did not complain about difficulties
of male menopause while being a junior
lecturer on sub Midwestern college
campus fantasy is without a shadow of a
doubt the UR literature the the
beginning literature right the spring
from which all other literature has
flown up to a few hundred years ago no
one would have disagreed with this
because most stories were in some sense
fantasy back in the Middle Ages people
would have thought twice about bringing
in death as a character who would have a
role to play in the story Echoes of this
can be seen in Pilgrim's Progress for
example which hark back to a much
earlier type of Storytelling the Epic of
Gilgamesh is one of the earliest works
of literature and by the standard we
would apply now big muscular guys with
swords and certain Godlike connections
that's fantasy the national literature
of Finland the cavala Bea wolf in
England I cannot pronounce Baba Vita but
the Indian one you know what I mean the
national literature the one that
underpins everything else is by the
standards that we apply now a work of
fantasy now I don't know what you'd
consider the national literature of
America but if the words Moby Dicker
inching their way towards this
conversation whatever else it was it was
a work of fantasy fantasy is a kind of
plasma in which other things can be
carried I don't think that this is a
ghetto this is fantasy as almost a sea
in which other genres swim now it may be
that there has developed in the last
couple hundred years a subset of fantasy
which merely uses a different
iconography and that is if you like the
serious literature the booker prize
Contender fantasy can be serious
literature fantasy often has been
serious literature you have to be fairly
dense to think that Gulliver's Travels
is only a story about Guy having real a
real fun time among big people and
little people and horses and stuff like
that what the book was about was
something else fantasy can carry quite a
serious burden and so can humor so what
you're saying is strip away the trolls
and dwarves and things and put everyone
in a modern dress get them to agonize a
bit mentioned Virginia wolf a few times
and hey there I've got a serious novel
but you don't actually have to do that
and that is what a wonderful reply to
somebody who's being a bit pretentious
and has all these presuppositions about
the nature of genre and this also
hearkens back to you know
tolken uh you know famous essay about
fantasy literature on fairy stories and
Ursa K Len's uh sort of you know
followup on that from elfland to pypy I
think that's a really interesting
response following up on this in um Tim
Cadman this is in
2002 he's asked you've written some
science fiction but fantasy is clearly
your medium is there a reason for this
and patet says it depends I've done a
lot of interviews today and people are
even disagreeing as to whether disc
world is fantasy one lady said now don't
notice this it's fantasy for everybody
else no that's not right what was it
that's it she said fantasy for the rest
of us and then the reviewer says uh you
mean tolken versus tolken and the
Latter-Day fantasy mush that's out there
and pranchas says I would like the
record to state that you said mush in a
sense tolken doesn't count because he
stands outside the genre there's plenty
of people that read tolken but wouldn't
pick up a fantasy novel on the end of a
pair of tongs I suppose that
Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy is a
bit like sci-fi for the rest of us so
let's pause on that for a moment uh
we've already got three in interesting
references to say that tolken is outside
of the genre of fantasy what a startling
thing to make a claim about what does he
mean there well in a certain way tolken
who so many fantasy authors for a while
were copying essentially the formula for
is beyond the typical fantasy but this
notion of fantasy for the rest of us
being humorous fantasy being kind of a
picker resque but also somewhat serious
set of novels that the disc world is and
being analogized to Hitchhiker's Guide
to the Galaxy by Douglas Adams as sci-fi
stuff for the rest of us that isn't that
an interesting comparison there we'll
follow up on that in just a
moment in the the rest of this interview
he's asked do you think fantasy will
ever become a respectable genre what do
you think it would take to be become one
and pratchet says okay serious question
what is a respectable genre what makes
it
respectable and then the person says
probably because it's on the Shelf
marked literature and then pratchet says
well okay interesting I said before that
I once went into a Bookshop that on all
the works of Margaret Atwood on the
Shelf Mark literature except for the
handmaid's tale which is soft science
fiction not about ray guns but was in
the science fiction section I in Banks
is a guy who writes worries book
bookshops because they don't know where
to put them sometimes his non- sci-fi
stuff reads like sci-fi and I don't
think Ian gives us stuff about it and
good for him on that but it won't be on
the literature shelf because of
cherry-picking tolken is kind of okay
now because he was successful and made
Publishers a lot of money in the same
way people have been making comments
when they interview me that it's not
really like fantasy writing because it's
fantasy for the rest of us what we're
seeing here is actually okay we think
you might be good so we're going to cut
you away from the herd so then you're
not really a fantasy writer there's a
saying you must have heard if it's
science fiction it can't be good if it's
good it can't be science fiction I just
say I'm a fantasy writer live with it if
it's not what you think fantasy writing
is I suggest you broaden your
horizons so pranet you know once again
sort of questioning the presuppositions
about genre that people are making
basically just tropes now we get to a
really interesting
interview in elace web Neil Gaiman who
later on patet is going to collaborate
with does an interview with pratchet and
he says now notice he's how he's
pressing him on this aren't the wizard
and the tourist now this is in the very
first book the color of magic right
aren't the wizard and the tourist a
little reminiscent of Arthur Dent and
Ford prefect you can go a long way by
having two characters one of whom is
StreetWise and the other is innocent and
a lightning conductor for trouble and
you stick them together which is what
Douglas Adams and many other people have
done it's what I did and you get a sort
of sword and sorcery Laurel and Hearty
and so pratchet responds tolower the
tourist really believes that because
he's not really involved because he's a
tourist even though he could be in the
middle of a battle the thought that
something could could actually hurt him
doesn't enter into his scheme of things
and
um ging is going to follow up there are
points in the book where it almost reads
like Douglas Adams and then pratchet
says well I write like the last author
I've read I've had really to stop myself
writing like Larry nen for someone who's
a bit of a comedian as I am he's such an
obvious person to copy I've got to admit
that while I hate and despise trekkies H
fan can walk under a snake while a a
trucky treky can walk under a snake
wearing a bowler hat Hitchhiker's Guide
fans are a great bunch of guys the only
trouble is that sometimes people take it
seriously and then you begin to panic I
was so impressed by hitchhiker I've got
the world's only talking door very easy
microchip processor got a bloke to write
me some software and as you go through
it it says glad to be of service please
enjoy your trip through this door it's a
lot of fun but I get uneasy when people
take these things too seriously now none
of these are really straight on answers
to ga's questions aren't they but
pratchet is perfectly fine saying yep
Douglas Adams doing this thing over here
I'm doing something similar over here
I've read the guy then he's asked uh
couldn't some people take the color of
magic too seriously and he says I don't
imagine that some that anyone could take
it seriously I don't take it seriously
if World War III actually happens I want
to be the one to say as the mushroom
crowd erupts well that about wraps it up
for this lifetime you've got to say
something that's a great deal better
than ah but as you know a lot of the fun
is in taking something dead seriously
thus exposing the funny side of things
like the law of conservation of reality
which says that you can make a wine
glass move or appear to move as long as
all you're doing is moving photons but
you got to be really careful if you're
moving the wine glass by Magic in case
the law of conservation of reality Cuts
in and your brain is forced out of your
ears that's a dead steel from The Wizard
of Earth Sea by Earths l k Len right and
then he goes on but the color of magic
is the standup comic of fantasy there's
never been one in fantasy before it's so
humorless Conan is so humorless I love
the film but the book what a load of
trash so the book I'm doing now the
sequel to the color of magic there's a
direct steal from the film do you
remember that scene where they're all
sitting around a campfire going what the
best thing in life the wind in your hair
and the lamentation of the women folk
well in my book there's Cohen the
Barbarian who's 87 and when his turn
comes around he says good dentistry and
soft toilet paper a lifetime of sleeping
rough has taught him that what Ma really
matters are hot water bottles dentistry
and soft toilet paper I suppose that by
and large I think the books are an
homage to the people who've given us so
much enjoyment I just go for the soft
underbelly so very interesting interview
there let's move on to another one the
author our interview and uh man the
person interviewing says you know you
have disc World conventions based on
your series and uh Terry pratchet says
one of the things I like to do is get
kids reading and for some reason I don't
know why it is and lots of people have
been telling me at this convention it
tends to go like this you know my boy is
more or less dyslexic and wouldn't read
any books and I've got him on the disc
world and now he's a professor of
comparative linguistics at oxf for
University I think that's all about
writing fantasy it's a strange kind of
fantasy that I write it isn't like the
normal sort it's that it's uni AG you
can enjoy it as an adult and you can
enjoy it as a child but I always make
certain that the ones that are
expressedly children's books are written
with kids in mind because there's
nothing worse than pretending it's a
children's book but waving at Mom and
Dad over the top of the page that
sometimes happens if you get the
Carnegie medal for a children's book
book which I got for the amazing Morris
and his educated rodents there are
children's Librarians voting for that
and the kids themselves and they know if
it's a children's book or
not and then uh the interviewer says
yeah you know fantasy sometimes gets a
bad rap people say I don't really write
fantasy I have fantasy in my book but I
don't actually write fantasy and then
Gillan says oh yes oh my word yes it's
magical realism you know the trouble is
put it like this if I set a book in
Tombstone around the time of Wyatt her
and I put in the hers and the clanes and
horses and cacti and Silver Mines if I
put in one lousy Dragon they'd call it a
fantasy book and then he goes on and
says this is sort of echoing what he
said to the onion uh interviewer I think
it really works like this all fiction
must in some way be
fantasy science fiction in my
consideration is that when you go past
the reasonably possible and predictable
and then you're probably in the field of
fantasy and you've left the field of
science fiction behind I must confess
Doctor Who and Star Trek worry me a
little bit because there are too many
things that you can do by using the
modern equivalent of reversing the
polarity you can jaring your way out of
problems
and he goes on and he says you know it's
got to be a little bit more complex but
it's all good fun and it's decent
entertainment and then uh the
interviewer says I mean that's why me so
many people like it it we've got got
enough of normal life and then pratchet
says this well I mean you consider a
normal life let me tell you young man is
a fantasy let me tell you why two miles
down there you'll burn alive two miles
up there you'll choke to death you're
living on a ball of rock traveling
through space at an imaginatively high
speed and you are protected by the
effect of this by a tiny tiny little
amount of effectively natural radiation
shielding which is in Peril now at any
case the sun is warming up a bit we live
in a world where with these things and
these things we go to the movies and out
there is a real universe and it's a very
strange Universe we live in a science
fiction Universe now we have done for a
long time recently on a show in England
a celebrity said I hate all this space
travel what good space traveling ever
done well think about your mobile phone
think about the fact that now no longer
does anyone need to be lost on this
planet think about the way we take for
granted the news from another country on
the other side of the world and we
expect it to be delivered to us at the
speed of light we live in a science
fiction universe so you bloody well
better get used to
it what a great set of remarks about the
world that we live live in that it is
already either a science fiction or
fantasy Universe um coming back to the
tolken matter he's asked by Milford
writers and this is in uh 1999 he says
would you say that tolken for all his
virtues has been kind of a bad thing
there in printing fantasy with this
default Assumption of whole races a
genetically programmed bad guys like the
Orcs And pratus says H does it start
with
tolken all he was doing was echoing a
very def definitive human trait classify
them as Orcs And you can kill them
easier cuz they ain't human but he's
certainly impressed on the public
Consciousness against the Run of History
the idea of elves is the good guy and
then he's asked uh 10 years ago or so I
seem to remember you muttering you might
move on from disc World obviously you're
still finding it fruitful was it a
matter of getting your second wind or
consciously deciding to take more risks
and push at the boundaries and Prat it
said it was the second and finding whole
novels and throw away lines take Uber
vaal a huge Empire is crumbled a lot of
political certainties have gone there's
new alliances there's a lot of
residences there that I didn't realize
existed when I put it on the discor map
what I hope to do is a non- disor
fantasy in the near future but I know
there are more disc novels several of
them with a entirely new cast and then
he's asked so there's no end in sight
and pratchet said you know I've said
I'll never knowingly write the last disc
world no but it has to evolve to keep
going if I had written 25 versions of
the light fantastic by now I'd be ready
to slip my wrists and then he's asked
but some fantasy authors who we'd better
not name have done more or less exactly
that and pratchet said um well that's
interesting maybe I'd have sold a few
more books been considered a moderately
successful author kept the day job and
by now would have had early retirement
from National Power or maybe something
even more weird may have happened then
he's asked now here we get to you know
these novels in particular that we're
interested in you said in the past the
fans always ask for more appearance of
the wizardly super coward rincewind has
he now been retired bearing in mind the
extremes to which you could keep pushing
vimes and Granny Weather Wax do you
think you'll ever take the big step of
killing off these or other long running
characters then pratchet says in the
next couple of years a major character
will die I know this because I've
written it but wait will not be what you
expect rincewind will probably be back
alas it is hard to make him more than
two-dimensional though I have not given
a lot of thought to killing off the
seriously big characters and it's quite
hard to see how you could kill Granny
but I could see them gently
retiring then he's asked why alas to the
thought of rinn's return you're the
master of disc World After All will the
fans send you off dead rats if you fail
to give rincewind another outing and
Prat says oh no I I quite like him and
he's useful but it's hard to do a lot
with him he's basically an observer he's
shallow all the way to the bottom he
makes a useful appearance in The Last
Hero which will be a book illustrated by
Paul kidby um I've written the story and
the artwork I've seen is very very good
right and then he's asked in l space web
a little bit later on by Sarah Bine um
interesting times was it written because
fans wanted more rincewind in flower and
pratchet says well in a way fans always
want the last book they read again and
if I'd listened to them by now I would
have written 16 books about Rin wind and
the luggage and 16 books about death
which I've always said was hang in there
let me write what I want to right and
you'll probably like it I knew that
people would like another rincewind one
I've never really forgotten about him
he's been around since Eric but I I
didn't do it just because they wanted
one and then he's asked something we
we've looked at already will you ever
give up the Discworld books and he says
to the best of my knowledge no one is
very anxious to see the disc world
stop I think my Publishers have
palpitations at the very thought I'm
sorry to say I've already had very some
good ideas for what two more books could
be about what I'm saying is there there
won't be a new disc world book in the
spring one reason is it's all you
buggers it's a traveling the signing
tour and the mail sleets up it's become
unreal I'll go on right
but they're not all going to be dis
World Books I'll do a dis world book
when I want to I like to do other things
too and finally the the last interview
that I'm going to bring up is in faster
than
life and it has to do with some what we
could call Trendy topics of the time for
the last couple uh decades or so and um
he's asked why did you choose
transgender topics for example the
female dwarf striving to become
recognized as female the Dr Queens in
the last continent Sergeant knobs
exploration of his female side in the
recent books was this motivated by
political activism of your side for gay
or transgender rights personal
experiences uh or you being Witnesses of
struggle of transgendered friends or
relatives and pratchet very
interestingly says none of the
above the dwarvish issue arose
originally out of the established fact
that fantasy folklore rarely deals with
female dwarfs and acts as if they don't
exist Ergo female dwarfs exist and they
look like male dwarfs Ergo their society
does not differentiate between the sex
once the kids are weaned Ergo this
Society is going to be very interesting
to write about when it comes into
contact with human society I have to
admit that unfolding it and exploring
the issues in my own mind has been
fascinating Nai well Nai is exploring
the wonderful world of being Nai though
I've never thought of him as being gay
in fact given his General repulsiveness
he probably doesn't even get much of a
chance to be straight and the Priscilla
takeoff Priscilla Queen of the Desert uh
it was because a it's a really great
Australian movie and B is a frequent
visitor to Australia I'm always amused
at how firmly rooted Gay Culture appears
to be there and there were run-on jokes
such as rince win's complete failure to
understand what's going on the poor poor
girl who's joined the trio to replace
her brother he says the people who I
know are gay and one trans gendered I
think like the dwarves I don't ask
people what they're not prepared to
volunteer are mostly within sci-fi
fantasy fandom which appears at least to
be quite amiable about people's
sexuality as long as they don't act like
a
jerk so then he's asked do you think
transgender characters are more common
and more accepted in science fiction
fantasy than in other genres and he says
yes as above without a shadow of a
doubt then he's asked so far all your
transgender gender characters has been
male to female oriented or female to
female if one chooses that view can we
expect some of the other direction and
he says let's start with the fact I
wouldn't be a good author if I sat down
and said right I'm going to explore the
issue of Fillin issue of the moment this
stuff evolves from the characters it has
to now he gets asked a very interesting
question here did any of your Publishers
or lectors criticize your use of such
protagonists how about letters from fans
was the residents more positive or more
negative and pratchet says You must have
a funny idea about Publishers the discor
books make them a lot of money and no
one knows why you think they're going to
turn around and tell me off as for the
fans those interested in what's going on
write very positively those who aren't
don't
notice finally he's asked did you intend
parallels from angua's the werewolf
situation and feet of clay to the coming
out problematic of gay lesbian and
transgender persons and once again
pratchet says something you know similar
to what he's already uh laid out I
invented angua simply because I could
see the character depth available with a
person who is half wolf half human and
not at home in either Society I had no
other motive but it soon became clear
how the parallels were developing and
this is a theme that you see a lot
within pret's work uh and and his
discussions about his work in interviews
he doesn't say oo I'm going to do this
programmatic thing let me see how I can
incorporate this theme that I really
care about that's you know connected to
contemporary politics he just writes and
the stuff is going to emerge naturally
out of the characters and their problems
and the plot and the
situations and where there's
opportunities for some sort of humor and
seriousness so we we really get a lot of
insight about not just these particular
five novels that were looking at that
feature rincewind and of course the
luggage pretty uh centrally but also
pret's larger work the disc World Series
and all of his other work as a
whole we're reaching the end of the time
that we've been allotted for this
discussion of these five disc World
novels by Terry pratchet and I do want
to bring in at least one kind of
philosophical theme and let to think a
bit about the humor involved in these
books and obviously we can't go
incredibly deep into all the examples
that are provided as somebody's pointed
out in in the past there's lots and lots
of puns involved in this which makes you
kind of think of you know Piers Anthony
as well in the fantasy genre with the
Zan novels uh and you know perhaps of
Douglas Adams as well in in sci-fi but
this character rincewind is a very funny
guy who doesn't think that much is funny
and doesn't go about trying to be comic
or humorous as now he's not you know
bads spirited or everything is serious
ious but he is a wizard who's not a very
good wizard at all as a matter of fact
he can't remember any spells or do much
of any of them in part because he has
that other one crowding out all of the
other spells stuck in his
head um he has to handle a lot of
different situations he gets sort of
brought in as a what would you call them
allaround jack of all trades not just
just in Magic but with negotiations and
guiding people and death uh develops a
kind of grudging respect perhaps for
rinn because he escapes death so many
times and he's framed as being a coward
so he's not a hero which okay W Heroes
and wizards as we learn don't really mix
with each other either they're
suspicious of each other but he's not
he's not even a remotely heroic wizard
and so he makes
this great foil for the other characters
that are involved he's always got an
observation to make but he's also
somebody perhaps very relatable to to us
and and he winds up being funny without
intending to and pratchet is a very good
funny writer let's say I I just want to
give you one example of an observation
set of observations that he uh gives
here and this is in the light
fantastic and he's talking about um oh
here's a great thing it's a well-known
fact Warriors and wizards do not get
along because one side considers the
other side to be a collection of
bloodthirsty idiots who can't walk and
think at the same time the other side is
naturally suspicious of a body of men
who Mumble a lot and wear long dresses
oh say the Wizards if we're going to be
like that then what about all those
studded collars and oiled muscles down
the young men's Pagan Association to
which the heroes reply that's a pretty
good allegation coming from a bunch of
wimpos who won't go near a woman on
account can you believe it of their
mystical power being sort of drained out
and
anyway says this sort of things has been
going on for
centuries uh in fact the hero even at
this moment Galloping toward the vortex
Plains didn't get involved in this kind
of argument because they didn't take it
seriously but mainly because this
particular hero was a heroin a redheaded
one now there's a tendency at a point
like this to look over one's shoulder at
the cover artist and start going on at
length about leather thigh boots and
naked blades words like full round and
even per creep into the narrative until
the writer has to go and have a cold
shower and a lie down so he's kind of
like breaking the fourth wall as we say
and then here's where it gets good which
is all rather silly because any woman
setting out to make a living by the
sword
isn't about to go around looking like
something off the cover of the more
advanced kind of lingerie catalog for
the specialized buyer oh well all right
the point that must be made is that
although herena the henah haired herodin
would look quite stunning after a good
bath a heavy duty manicure and The Pick
of the leather racks and wo Hans Lings
Oriental Exotica and Marshall Aids on uh
hero street she was currently quite
sensibly dressed in light chain mail
soft boots and a short sword all right
maybe the boots were leather but not
black riding with her were a number of
sthy men that will certainly be killed
before too long anyway so description is
probably not essential she's not even
going to bother describing her followers
her henchmen right there was absolutely
nothing about any of them look they can
wear leather if you like right so great
sort of takedown of the fantasy heroin I
mean this stuff is still going on today
isn't it in cartoons and video games and
you're like that's not practical to wear
a chain mail bra or something like that
and and you know pratchet is good at at
skewering
that um coming back to to rincewind this
is in interesting times um he's asked uh
about
um uh the luggage right and the the
luggage um now what is the luggage we've
talked about this a little bit it
becomes a follower of rincewind it is a
sensient type of you know essentially
what what it's called luggage and this
is a product of the Mage Wars that have
like Turned certain kinds of wood into
the things that can be sensient but it
ends up reproducing rince wind says oh
you turned up at last have we what
happened to the follow following Master
everywhere thing the luggage shuffled
its feet from out of an Alleyway came a
slightly larger and far more innate
version of itself its lid was inset with
decorative wood and it seemed to rinse
wood its feet were rather more dainty
than the horny nailed callous ones of
the luggage besides the toenails had
been painted oh he said well good grief
fair enough I suppose really I mean yes
well come on that it's very flustered
right and so uh
we we hear this rinn's own sexual
experiences were not excessive though
he'd seen diagrams he hadn't the
faintest idea about how it applied to a
travel accessories did they say things
like what a chest or get a load of the
hinges on that one if it came to that he
had no reason for considering that the
luggage was male admittedly it had a
homicidal nature but so had a lot of the
women rinin had met and it often become
a little more homicidal as a result of
meeting him capacity for violence rinin
had heard was seexual he wasn't sure
what unisex was but expected it was what
he normally experienced so you know this
is this is a great you know example of
his
Pros pratchet is very very
funny and he he doesn't seem to have to
work awfully hard at being funny though
the pros just the way it's set up has a
certain kind of measure to it it's
joking and as we saw in the interviews
right it can't be comedy all the time
you have to have a certain element of
seriousness to it the world has to be up
for grabs or in danger or people's lives
have to be put at risk and then you can
actually make it quite funny and the we
could say that in pret's Works in these
novels uh throughout the the disc world
and you know particularly those that are
centered on rinse
uh which include more than these five
but do include these these particular
volumes what we have
are centering a narrative around
rincewind and other characters in ways
that inevitably turn out to be funny you
tilt things just slightly and they
become inous they become you know if we
want to think about the the older ways
of understanding standing
comedy we take the elevated and we bring
it down a bit not in the mean nasty way
of like putting it down in the dirt you
know the cynical in the modern sense
debunking rather it's just showing that
everything's got its flaws in in a sense
you could say that and this is a good
place to
close it's almost platonic right Plato
in a variety of places
will tell us that nothing that we
experience within this world of things
that we have a a form an idea an
archetype a pattern of for instance
Justice nothing is truly what it is and
we can see that in any just action any
just person any just Arrangement there
is some injustice there
similarly we have for any hero for any
great wizard for any amazing Noble
action there's always something that's
not that way and we could be cynical
about and be you see a bunch of
Hypocrites but we could also see it as
comical as humorous and that is a
response to life and that gets brought
in over and over and over again in these
very novels and so that's a great place
I think to close with these disc World
novels centered around but not
exclusively about the character
rincewind who always seems to find a way
out of the situations the traps that he
is caught in manages to survive every
once in a while does something that
turns out to be great usually not
intending to do so and so we'll bring
this to a close and I look forward to
discussion uh with those who can attend
the session after this premieres and to
your comments and questions that you can
leave
[Music]
below